you
alright team black gotta get thinking
immediately a night in the corner is an
ugly ugly sight all right what's
unprotected this guy he cannot be hit
though by White's first no there's no if
there was a bishop here see for striking
at this
what would my first move be hmm I think
it might be
f-five opens up this diagonal but also
helps out my queen where do I think I'm
in a castle in order to castle I need to
Castle kingside I need to move my Queen
in my bishop he could stay put I'm
liking f5 one of these four pawn moves
is pretty much how I start in Fisher
random though I might want to consider
something else well not this right now
because of the bishop however I think
that this is a good start
mmm although hang on pawn push here
mm-hmm I don't think I have any fear of
that let's get him in pawn to f5 Bishop
takes pawn out premium of that okay I'm
not quite sure where my bishop belongs
if white plays f4 what would I really do
next hmm
okay what's he up to any dangerous
things for just a brief moment I was
thinking I'll just give my Bishop up for
the ninth but that's crazy I'm not even
damaging the structure in any way the
Knights there to recapture I think I
might want to follow suit yeah let's do
that
oh boy wait a second is night here gonna
be a bug I should be able to defend that
without any issues well though I don't
know about that hang on I don't want to
do this
it's just I'm asking for trouble
weakening these light squares
hmm what a bug man really huh he's
already going after this pawn how dare
you Wow I already feel like I'm in
uncomfortable position move tool that's
Richie random right there man like night
to 85 scares me it really does and it
should scare me right 95 push night here
smothered mate well I have to give my
rook up and then my Knights dead okay I
might need to do this move um be six
just stop any night nonsense here uh no
I don't need to do that how about I push
here I guess I was just seeing things
I'm gonna I'm gonna do this yeah white I
wasted all that time seeing things that
weren't really so dangerous
I could play e4 but you could be sure
that that pun will be undermined if I'm
placing upon and white side of the board
these are the moves that immediately
come to mind ones that strike at it
f3 e3 this Bishop doesn't want to be
shut out of the game so this is an idea
another idea I had is to meet Knight a5
with this okay now I'm definitely doing
that so he's kind of a dead piece if you
don't do anything about this structure
he's a cooked duck right here in the
corner God do something so now what
comes to mind undermining this pawn
chain you could strike at the tail which
is the first thing that should maybe
come to mind okay that's good okay I
think I just oh my goodness wow this is
so dangerous already do you see how
dangerous this is
look at this Bishop he's ready to kill
me push take
takes rook takes Queen takes bishop here
oh I could block with my knight that's
super scary though I must say maybe I
should run for the hills wow this is
uncomfortable really uncomfortable okay
wow this is super uncomfortable
okay I'm Mike King is going to just take
a hike I'm down to less than two minutes
we're only four moves in but this is a
really wacky position so that's my
excuse for taking so much time it's a
really wacky position so I guess this is
also a good idea in reinforcing well now
I mean I could have gone there anyway
but my main idea was to simply run away
oh man oh this is a this is a this is
probably not a good move because I get
to defend and throw a punch at the
knight wow this is certainly one of the
more complicated positions I've
encountered in Fisher random okay next
up I should probably develop a piece
they can all bond moves okay
Wow f5 e 5 g 6 c 6 calling all pieces
these guys need to do something I'm not
really gonna have anything insightful to
share after this game Wow ok so I don't
even know how to even make this look
like a regular chess position I don't
know I mean I don't even know how to
make it look half decent or half
coordinated looking he's a bum in the
corner and here King here Knight here
I've oh hang on I could Castle queenside
though I'm not sure that that's so
helpful what's he up to now I should
probably get my other night working
minute 30 I got a 1
at time disadvantage I'm also now able
to play here without any fork so that's
a good thing is this not going to be
annoying I can't do this because then
both Knights are trained on e6 but I
could give them a kick with v6 I may
have to do this anyhow because of the
bishop having pressure here though you
know what where does this Knight move to
next cuz he's kind of stuck there's
there's no safe square for the knight
what's this up no what's the story with
this I don't know let's let's let's
clear out another piece yeah I guess
just develop I mean I'm playing it feels
only on two ranks at the board I have
one pawn on my opponents side of the
board but everything else is just it
seems half developed a Castle queenside
I could play here but maybe that's
helping white to open up this file one
day so what can I do to make progress
okay let's let's get this in
should I take here and then push I'm
gonna go with that I'm gonna take that
guy out and then push here he's my bad
bishop oh I forgot about that that was
stupid
alright let's shut down this bishop well
I could still do this soon he was my bad
bishop anyway alright he's insisting on
that let me let me get another pawn up
in the center so I'm playing I'm playing
against their light square bishop he's
kick it into a higher gear alright let's
see if I could um close it up force him
to take I want to play my rook here okay
they they did that so I could castle on
this side of the board I could have
taken that pawn I'm soon going to do
that probably next no I want to contest
this file I finally have some
coordination yeah I'm doing I'm doing
better right now I'm ready to grab that
pawn be
- I'm gonna take him now definitely he's
a dead piece in the corner and then
let's drop back here he's unprotected
I'm just gonna push him 31 seconds could
take that night my Knights didn't need
to do a better job okay let's get my
night right here on d6 you can throw
them in here 27 seconds I need to get
rid of that night get him out of there
I'm defending here let's keep pushing
I'm gonna take that night Oh Knights
Knights versus bishops where does my
knight belong right here there's a home
get there he definitely needs to get
there and fast oh I have a passed pawn
to connect to past pawn I don't want to
move the knight so quick cleaning a pin
yeah oh I could do this no not here my
Knights a good defender though he come
over here I'm at strictly defensive 14
seconds uh okay I meant hitting the rook
here Queen trade he can't come over here
and contest the file okay I'm a little
bit more happy here let me really take
that can the other night work and
finally here here I could take here if
Bishop takes I'm on the Rope twice let's
then two eyes missing missing that it's
falling now everything is hit and it's a
lot more clean at this point a lot more
clean a little stepladder they're right
at the end oh man what a complicated
game oh man getting I had some serious
fears if you didn't realize let's go
back quickly I'm not gonna have much to
offer with this one these are just
playing they're fun and let's get out of
here and not even stare at that butt
never again you may never see that
position ever again okay so I'm gonna
see how things were from your side of
the board if I look for my side I'm
gonna get scared again this was this is
the move I spent so much time being so
concerned about 9 to 85 hmm yeah like
night here right now oh I got to do this
this one really scared me I don't know
this is this is good this is the right
way it feels like hmm
feels like you were on the black that we
have the black pieces and we're playing
a Benko gambit undermining this
structure and the rook is already
well-placed to facilitate this advance
so you're striking at the tail of this
structure you also have that option
striking at the head so yeah maybe
instead the night I wonder I wonder if
you could just go forward with taking
here or even immediately giving this
check this is the one that was bugging
me and I was really sweating that one
out this check that's why I did this so
my king could just run if I again I
think if I did this there's a couple
takes my queen is on this square Bishop
check I have to block with my knight
normally my King can't run away so
easily it's an uncomfortable pin what a
messy start to this game what kind of
position was this again knight in the
corner rook in between both nights yeah
when these Knights are both on one side
of the board it could be really really
messing this is this was one of the
Messier ones I've experienced sometimes
just after a handful of moves you'll be
like oh this is kind of like the dragon
structure or this particular opening but
not in this game this is when you first
look at this you could clearly tell it's
a Fischer random game and I'm really
speechless I don't even know what to
suggest I mean it was it was it was a
tough game
I gave up my bishop you should try to be
getting him activated with like this
move okay you're prying open the a file
you're contesting the a file I think
instead of closing it up maybe maybe you
should take and then play rook here you
know in such a closed position this
might be an interesting idea to give up
the exchange only to maybe activate the
dark square Bishop takes let's say here
if you want to be assured that I'm
taking back with the pawn I have at
least a few more options if you're
taking on c4 but if you wanted to make
sure I just have pawns on c4 and a4 you
could take here and after the recapture
rook to b4 I can put pressure on it but
maybe you just played Bishop b6 and say
go ahead take my bishop because then
he's gonna spring right to life
so in these fairly close positions you
know ignoring this a file being opened
this might be an interesting exchange
sacrifice so it's it's not just helpful
to the bishop but pawn structure wise
this is of course a great asset because
you would then have connected passed
pawns the guy on b4 all right we didn't
go there we went into a more closed
position I started to feel a lot more
comfortable here and I think at this
point I am better but I don't I'm not so
sure about my decisions
well we're losing a pawn here something
needs to be done with that but we're
kind of at least I'm in bullet mode here
but that was overlooked I had that
option for a few turns but I wanted to
make sure I had my books connected
before I grabbed here and I wasn't so
happy this is really and I didn't want
to do this maybe I should have just
immediately pushed I don't know maybe
maybe you're able to jump in here but
he's kind of a dead piece I think this
needed to happen much sooner to do
something about this pawn on the white
side of the board he was far too
cramping and another thing by capturing
on this a Foursquare you know when you
played this I think the very first
thought I had
as soon as that move was played I think
my first thought was okay good I'll be
able to have a safe home for my king
so when I castle on this side of the
board nothing Bad's gonna happen over
here so that's I was pointing out this
idea of an exchange sacrifice with Duke
to before but there's also with this
move with this locking up type of move
comes now King security that was a
thought that I had and so that's I was a
little bit more at ease when I saw this
move
okay Queen c2 never really broke at this
so I'll always have some lasting
advantage in the form of space so I'm
not sure that this is the ideal
environment really for the bishops it's
too locked of a structure got kicked
around we're just going crazy at this
point and he's always a constant
annoyance but I should have maybe even
considered just pushing and then
throwing my knight in here that would be
probably a good idea and just play
against this dark square Bishop yeah it
takes it takes forever for this bishop
to get activated this is the only open
diagonal no but we're just going crazy
at this point all right good game
love the Fisher random games
you